major major conspiracy theories swirling
around Democratic presidential candidate
Hillary Clinton's health
Alex Jones's conspiracy site Infowars
Breitbart both very involved in
spreading those conspiracies they put up
a picture from February of an icy winter
day when Hillary Clinton had slipped on
ice to suggest that in the last few
weeks she was frail and unstable on her
feet they're slowing down video of her
in a few different moments to the
campaign to make it look like she has
these extended periods of instability
and disorientation etcetera etcetera
etcetera but the real story might be
elsewhere
remember when late last year Trump
released a letter purportedly from his
doctor talking about how just how
awesome Trump's health is in every way
his tests are tremendous he tested so
well for everything blah blah blah blah
blah he did very very well he did very
very well on that doctor's letter he
finally won again with that doctor's
letter all of the attention on Hillary's
supposed medical records gave a doctor
named Jennifer Gunter the idea to look
more closely at that letter but that
Donald Trump supposedly received from
his doctor and she determined that the
Trump letter actually warrants quite a
bit of scrutiny let's start first with
just showing you if you're watching here
the letter big picture okay
this is the letter reportedly from the
office of Jacob Bornstein and Herald
Bornstein both doctors and okay
it's a letter first problem is as you
see there the first line is to whom my
concern already strange because
typically these letters are written with
some kind in English incorrect grammar
but maybe from a template or it's a very
short letter so how you know very well
fine is just a typo maybe doesn't really
mean too much second problem with the
letter is it doesn't even have a working
web address if you go to Herald
Bornstein MD dot-com which is there you
get a missing website redirect the sort
of placeholder page which I'll show you
uh in terms of what it looked like as of
this morning and it's one of these
websites that show up essentially when
there is no website there whatever
domain registrar's be
use put something up there in addition
to this dr. Gunter says it's very weird
that a doctor would even include their
email address in this kind of letter
because number one uh if you're making a
media release about someone so notables
health you don't want to get a flood of
emails and that relates to reason number
two why you wouldn't include an email
address which is you can't say anything
HIPAA laws would not allow you if people
start emailing you as a result of this
letter what would you tell them you
can't tell them anything because HIPPA
laws preclude you from doing that
uh now let's move on to the bottom of
the letter to look at something else and
if you look at the bottom of the letter
you'll see that it refers to the
Department of Medicine section of
Gastroenterology at Lenox Hill Hospital
in New York City Lenox Hill has a
division of Gastroenterology not a
section and by the way dr. Bornstein
isn't even listed on the website as a
member of that uh division we will show
you a picture of who is listed there dr.
swaminathan doctor correlates and cut
the day in and David Herbert Robbins in
Anthony Starr Polly but number one no
section of gastroenterology even exists
at this hospital and the division uh
does not even list dr. Bornstein dr.
Bornstein is affiliated with Lenox Hill
but he has nothing to do with
gastroenterology why would he sign the
letter that way why is it referred to by
a name that is not even the name of the
actual gastroenterology department it's
all very very strange
and then lastly according to dr. Gunther
the language of the letter is very very
strange I think we have a bit of this to
show you as well
no doctor describes tests as quote only
positive results nor astonishingly
excellent it is also very weird that a
doctor would reserve refer to results as
positive because usually in medical
language when you've tested positive for
something when a test is positive that
means you have a condition or disease
you would not if you were
trying to talk about how great someone's
health is say oh all the tests were so
positive because in medical language a
positive test means yes you do have a
condition that we are testing for weird
isn't it very strange yeah my guess
would be that this was just some type of
favor right that this was just a favor
that the the Donald Trump asked for and
I well billionaires who knows if he's
relieving a billionaire sore I have a
way to get these favors and maybe that's
what this was all so completely
unbelievable that the letter would say
this is the healthiest individual this
would be the healthiest individual ever
to be elected to the presidency doctors
usually exercise caution uh doctor dr.
Bornstein certainly did not examine the
health of every President of the United
States so how on earth could he make the
determination that Trump would be the
healthiest president of the United
States unless Jason this is a doctor who
in addition to having very very weird
formatted letters had a time machine or
something like that
pressure is a time machine he also wrote
the other letter about Hillary and maybe
maybe some letters to uh you know
maintain aliens or some other conspiracy
theories I can think of but yeah very
very strange and lastly the header can
we put that the full letter back up just
for a second uh Jason the the the first
image that we had for the segment you'll
notice that the letter in at the top
refers to Jacob Bornstein and Harold
Bornstein uh as far as we know not not
both of those doctors were still alive
as of 2015 uh so so that's yet another
wrinkle in the entire thing maybe this
was some old copied and pasted header I
don't know if we're going to start
scrutinizing medical letters this is
definitely at the top of my list I don't
know about you
we were not ones to buy into conspiracy
theories this thing is this something's
up with this there's something very very
strange about the send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman I've talked
about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is Zipcar which gets you
a car when you want it when you need it
they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need
includes insurance and it includes gas
you just pay for the time that you
actually use the car and you can reserve
the car online from your smartphone over
the phone then you unlock it with your
zip card each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1600 pounds per year for our
audience
Zipcar is offering $25 a free driving
credit if you sign up at join Zipcar
dot-com slash david support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join Zipcar
dot-com slash David